this is lithium pretty soon we're going
to need a lot of it lithium is a useful
metal it spends its entire existence
trying to get rid of its one outer
electron but crucially this reaction can
be both controlled and reversed that
means properly configured the metal can
discharge energy when needed take in
more energy and then discharge that
energy essentially it can act as a
battery it's only been a few decades
since lithium-ion batteries reach
commercial feasibility but in that time
they have become the power source of
choice for portable electronics thanks
to their perfect blend of safety and
lightness
however the latest major tech boom the
latest infatuation of silicon valley and
wall street alike is centered around the
largest consumer electronics product to
date electric vehicles and pretty soon
we're going to need a lot of them the uk
for example has committed to banning
internal combustion car sales by 2030 to
replace its three one and a half million
vehicles about 236 000 metric tons of
lithium carbonates are needed to produce
236 000 metric tons of lithium carbonate
every lithium mine in the world would
have to devote its output to this one
use for nine months and there are a
whole lot more countries a whole lot
more lithium applications and a whole
lot more growth in the forecast while
the industry and its issues may be
complex the way in which battery grade
lithium is produced is not
four countries dominate the industry
argentina chile australia and china
combined account for 92 percent of the
globe's production the metal is
extracted from the ground at massive
sites like the green bushes mine in
western australia
which is the world's largest hard rock
lithium mine the site was selected due
to the abundance of spodamine in the
area which is a mineral that contains
large concentrations of lithium once the
raw material is extracted from the
ground is transported two and a half
hours north to the quinana lithium plant
near perth a facility a majority owned
and operated by a chinese company chunky
lithium which is responsible for almost
half of the world's production of the
metal once refined lithium hydroxide and
other compounds are sold to battery
manufacturers which in about three
quarters of cases means one of three
companies lg chem catl or panasonic
the problem however is the world's
solution in addition to the uk iceland
belgium the netherlands germany denmark
norway sweden israel singapore and south
korea have each committed to banning the
sale of internal combustion passenger
vehicles within the next decade adding
up their annual passenger vehicle sales
numbers from 2019 that means the
absolute base case demand for evs a
decade from now will be 9.5 million per
year just to reach that eevee production
would have to quintuple but even the
most conservative forecasters don't dare
tread anywhere close to a number as low
as 9.5 million in 2032 the market is
waking up to what this means for lithium
demand across 2021 seabourn lithium
prices rose from around 8 000 per metric
ton to over 30 000
a 400 rise in a mere 12 months and
lithium is hardly the only crucial metal
for lithium-ion battery production it's
just the one in the name cobalt and
nickel are also critical to most
commercially available versions of these
batteries and the situation is hardly
different with them cobalt prices
doubled across 2021 while nickel rose to
its highest price in a decade
so the world needs a lot more medals but
right now it's hard to believe the
world's going to get them
the biggest hurdle the industry faces is
exemplified here thacker pass nevada
thacker pass is located in one of the
most sparsely populated areas of the
country it's a half hours drive to the
nearest store an hour to the nearest
supermarket and three to the nearest
starbucks the few roads that exist in
the area are lucky to see a few cars an
hour traveling to and from the various
remote farms ranches and communities
dotting northern nevada that could soon
change though 250 miles or 400
kilometers to the south is the silver
peak lithium mine this is the nation's
only currently operating major lithium
mine despite the fact that the us is one
of the largest ev markets and home to
the world's largest ev manufacturer
china also a major ev market home to
major ev manufacturers has made
significant headway in building up its
domestic lithium production capacity and
the country's companies also have
significant presences at the world's
other major lithium production sites
this has come to concern those in charge
in the u.s therefore sites are set on
thacker pass home to the us's largest
lithium deposit the site could
single-handedly propel the us into the
ranks of major lithium producers but
getting a mine up and running there has
proved
difficult
the way in which major lithium deposits
are distributed across the world is
rather cruel overwhelmingly they're
located in arid regions with little
water availability like nevada
thacker pass receives less than 10
inches or 25 centimeters of rain a year
however the extraction and processing of
lithium requires enormous quantities of
water it's expected that operations at
the proposed thack or pass lithium mine
would require 3 224 gallons or 12 204
liters of water per minute roughly
equivalent to the contents of a backyard
above ground pool that water would be
used to pump into the ground as part of
the extraction process during refinement
and to conduct necessary dust control at
the site
to get this water the mine would have to
pump it out of the ground using wells
but every acre foot of water in the area
is strictly allocated given the degree
of scarcity so the mine has to buy up
water rights from others in order to
gain the legal right to use it what that
means however is that there's a direct
trade-off between one use and another
and in this case the other use is
predominantly ranching and farming two
key tenants to the local economy in
addition there's a chance the project
could do far more to further the
inaccessibility of water in northern
nevada the us bureau of land
management's environmental impact study
for the project found that it presented
the distinct possibility of leaking
unacceptable levels of arsenic into the
area's groundwater table which could
take the entire region's water supply
offline for hundreds of years in an area
where the availability of water
undergirds almost all economic activity
that has people seriously concerned the
issues only compound on top of that as
thackerpass is of course a mountain pass
it acts as a wildlife corridor between
the double h and montana mountains two
biodiversity hot spots therefore the
environmental impact study found the
project likely to destroy or deteriorate
thousands of acres of habitat used by
the pronghorn antelope sage grouse
golden eagle and other unique species
for interrelated reasons the project
also has a number of local indigenous
tribes concerned the most vocal of which
is the fort mcdermott paiute and
shoshone tribe they say that during the
era of american soldiers rounding up and
shipping indigenous people off to
reservations two of the tribe's families
hid out in the shelter thacker pass
provided so they directly attribute the
continued existence of their tribe to
the area in addition they consider the
past a sacred site in part because of a
historic massacre they say occurred
there this assertion however was
directly challenged in a court case
related to the mine project and the
judge rejected the claim citing a lack
of evidence to add to their opposition
the tribe put forward evidence linking
the development of similar resource
extraction projects which are
predominantly staffed by men to
increases in the rape and murder of
indigenous women in nearby areas
even just looking at these few headline
issues it becomes clear that the fact or
past lithium mine project is mired in a
nearly insurmountable web of controversy
and conflict and it's hardly alone in
that status much of the evidence
opponents to the fact or past mine have
put forward is based on real world
experiences in the lithium triangle the
nexus between chile argentina and
bolivia that host some of the world's
most productive lithium production
facilities an area in a similar
situation a remote arid landscape
punctuated by small communities home to
a historically oppressed indigenous
population the lithium triangle has seen
an economic boom but it's come at the
cost of environmental and cultural
devastation
just as the issues are not confined to
one geography they're not even confined
to lithium alone some 70 of the world's
cobalt a crucial component to current
battery tech comes from the democratic
republic of the congo the eighth poorest
country in the world according to world
bank figures while a majority of the
cobalt mining is conducted by large
mining companies with often shaky safety
and human rights records a concerningly
large minority is accomplished through
what's referred to as artisanal mining a
term defining the illegal informal
practice of individuals mining cobalt by
themselves and selling it on to shady
middlemen the complete lack of safety
standards or regulations in the sector
means child labor and deadly mind
collapses are rampant for those that
aren't directly injured or killed on the
job long-term exposure to cobalt mines
has been linked to significant health
effects later in life and fatal birth
defects for children in the region
altogether there's almost no such thing
as ethical cobalt there's also almost no
such thing as green lithium there's
little appetite anywhere to increasing
lithium mining in the places where it's
accessible and little progress has been
made in the drc in making cobalt mining
less socially disastrous
as demand for evs and their batteries
increases getting more cobalt in lithium
will be incredibly difficult however on
top of that getting more cobalt and
lithium that's more ethical and green or
even as ethical and green will be next
to impossible but to decarbonize driving
solutions must be found
one option rather than finding more raw
materials is to need less of them of
course the way to do that is by making
batteries better the most promising
short-term innovation that could fulfill
that mission is solid-state batteries
whereas traditional ev batteries have a
liquidy viscous lithium-based
electrolyte solid-state batteries rather
use a solid metal composition as their
ion transport mechanism this switch has
a number of benefits including a higher
safety profile that reduces the risk of
fire and therefore reduces the need for
expensive safety features solid-state
batteries can also be made without
cobalt or nickel which eliminates two
problematic and costly necessities in
current battery tech most significant
however is solid state battery's higher
energy density traditional lithium ion
compositions used in ev battery packs
store about 114 watt hours of energy per
pound or 250 per kilogram
that means one pound of battery could
move a tesla model 3 for example 0.4
miles or 1 kilogram 1.3 kilometers
meanwhile it's expected that solid-state
batteries will be able to store between
175 and 225 watt hours per pound or 400
to 500 per kilogram essentially doubling
battery density that means tesla could
have the weight of their half-ton
battery pack and not only keep range the
same but increase it as the car would no
longer need to carry the rest of the
weight of the battery pack on top of all
those benefits experts believe that at
scale production costs of solid state
batteries could be even less than the
current cheapest lithium ion batteries
however the issue is getting to that
scale battery production needs to occur
at absolutely massive quantities to
reach cost competitiveness an assertion
backed up by the industry's current
effective triopoly the process of
working down this cost curve is long as
there are few applications where battery
weight matters as much as with evs and
evs won't switch to solid-state
batteries until their cost is
competitive but their cost will only
become competitive when the industry
reaches a production capacity that only
evs can provide
so the industry has to wait for some
level of scale to occur through niche
solid-state battery applications in
medical devices race cars and fighter
jets then wait for consumer electronics
to realize the weight savings or battery
life benefits the innovation could
provide then wait for the highest end
evs to incorporate the technology in
order to offer super long ranges as a
luxury before solid state batteries can
finally reach a cost that would allow
them to permeate into what will be by
then the large segment of everyday evs
most estimates place that enticing end
goal more than a decade away
even if the solid-state battery
transition reaches fruition earlier the
world will still need a whole lot more
lithium far from the potential
environmental disaster at thacker pass
is an existing environmental disaster
the sultan sea
a century ago colorado river flood
waters breached through an irrigation
canal and accumulated over years in the
imperial valley's geographic low point
236 feet or 72 meters below sea level
that massive puddle still exists today
but some of the water has slowly
evaporated through time leaving an even
saltier dirtier accumulation of water
thousands more feet below however are a
number of underground volcanoes that
superheat water to hundreds of degrees
if one brings that water to the surface
the pressure change leads to it
transforming into steam and steam of
course is what most power plants use to
drive turbines traditional power plants
use coal or natural gas to heat water up
into steam but this steam is created by
the earth meaning it's carbon free
that's why berkshire hathaway energy has
built 10 geothermal energy plants in the
area but crucially this superheated
water is filled with something else
lithium therefore these geothermal
plants are planning on adding an extra
step in their process to extract lithium
from the briny steam they use now there
are certainly significant technological
hurdles that stand between now and a
future of commercially competitive
lithium production at the salton sea
especially as the metal only represents
a tiny portion of the slurry of
materials found in the water but the
lithium is there
berkshire hathaway energy as the largest
existing energy company working around
the salton sea is leading the charge
thanks in part to a sizeable federal
grant and expects to have its
demonstration facility up and running
later in 2022 a number of other
competitors have already started
developing their lithium extraction
plays around the salton sea meaning
america's first lithium boom town might
already be a foregone conclusion
these are the kind of solutions needed
as the world transitions to electric
mobility electric vehicles due to their
reliance on batteries are just dirtier
than internal combustion vehicles to
produce
that being said the vast majority of
emissions from cars including from evs
themselves come not from the production
of vehicles but from driving them the
science on the issue is sound electric
vehicles from production to use to
scrapping are responsible for about 75
percent less emissions than their
internal combustion counterparts even on
current fossil fuel based electric grids
anyone who argues the opposite is either
misinformed or attempting to disinform
and that gap will only widen as grids
continue to decarbonize however there
can be better alternatives to better
alternatives in the coming lithium gold
rush corners can and likely will be cut
the question the world will have to
grapple with is whether it's worth
destroying pristine environments like
thacker pass in the name of
environmentalism whether slowing the
issue on a global level is worth
accelerating it on a local level
then when the answer inevitably
gravitates towards yes the world will
have to grapple with who must confront
that local devastation if the answer
continues to be to place the burden on
the world's most vulnerable then even if
the steady march of climate change is
curbed will the world have truly
succeeded in stopping its effects is it
worth sending teenagers to die in a war
to prevent the propagation of terrorist
organizations is it worth depressing an
economy to slow the spread of a pandemic
is it worth allowing individuals to own
guns for self-protection even if it
allows easier access for bad actors
determining what is an acceptable
sacrifice has historically led to some
of the most contentious perennial
political issues in history
here it's happening again the public
needs to decide with the fate of the
world on top of them
how much bad should be allowed for the
greater good
if you want to reduce your impact on the
environment one great place to start is
with hellofresh hellofresh is a meal kit
service that ships all the ingredients
you need for their recipes and exactly
the quantities you need the packaging is
made out of 100 recycled content and a
university of michigan study found that
hellofresh cut down on food waste by 25
compared to grocery shopping that makes
your meals greener but on top of that
hellofresh makes cooking a lot more
convenient thanks to those pre-portioned
ingredients your shopping time becomes
none and your prep time is reduced so it
means you can make fresh home-cooked
meals in less time i love the concept so
much that i used hellofresh for almost a
year before they came along and
sponsored us and still do to this day
for example last week i had the parmesan
chicken with garlic scallions couscous
and lemony roasted carrots for dinner
which as always was delicious and hello
fresh also makes things easier for you
if you're counting calories since they
just tell you the nutritional info for
each of their meals no more adding up
all the ingredients or approximating
altogether i love hellofresh since it
reduces my dependence on a healthy and
expensive freezer and delivery food and
helps me free up time so i'd encourage
you to try them out click the button on
screen or go to hellofresh.com and use
code wendover16 for up to 16 free meals
and three surprise gifts